[Music]
welcome to Hanson on the remote place on
the west coast of Canada
about ten kilometers long and two
kilometers wide this island belongs to
two groups the First Nations and the oka
for most of my life I've had the great
good fortune of living here in this
incredible environment and studying this
little creature and it's given me a
sense of peace in the world I want
everybody to have that same experience
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Paul Spong and 47 years ago I
was a young scientist at the University
of British Columbia and part of my job
was to study an author in captivity at
the Vancouver Aquarium I came to
understand that authors are acoustic
creatures because they're using sound to
locate their prey to get what they need
to live from sound
they should not be penned up in concrete
tanks that deprived them of the sounds
of the ocean that they were born into
ultimately that knowledge led me to
search for a place in the wild where I
could study office totally without
interfering with them and that search
led me to Hanson Island where I said a
polka lab we build a network of half a
dozen Hydra phones that cover 50 square
kilometers of the surrounding area and
they give us live audio so we can track
their movements often 24 hours a day 60
60 area for me one of the greatest
experiences here is putting on a pair of
earphones and just listening and then we
have speakers in the forest near the
temps you know the outhouse near the
camp kitchen all of the spaces around
here
one of the things you can't help
noticing and feeling is the sudden
intrusion of a boat of a vessel of a
propeller it's jarring
[Applause]
[Music]
here at Orca lab we listen to untold
quantities of boat noise it's really
annoying we can always walk away from
but whales can't that disrupts that
communication that disrupts their
ability to hunt I think from a point of
view of the welfare of the whales
something that has to be dealt with what
I want to do is develop the ability for
people to get to feel empathy for the
creature since 2000 we've streamed live
audio so that anybody with computer
access to the Internet can listen to
exactly what we listen to in our lab
what we're trying to do is give people a
taste of what it is to be an opener in
this magnificent environment in doing
that they will come to care and want to
protect nature
I believe that if I can share what I
have experienced the world could not
peace
[Music]
these organisms are beautiful and iconic
there's certain types that are present
nowhere else on earth so it's very
important to study them
my name is drew Laura and I'm the
principal investigator on science under
the ice science under the ice is what
we've been calling our project where
we've been studying the resilience of
organisms the seafloor organisms to
climate related changes and we do
science under the ice literally by scuba
diving under frozen ocean in Antarctica
the most recent trip was to explorers
Cove new harbour which is in the rough
sea Antarctica
our team was science scientists and
technicians and of those seven of them
for scientific divers underneath the ice
we are about to commence our dive
operations for the morning / afternoon
on this trip we went diving underneath
the ice to deploy large-scale experiment
involving the incubation chambers that
we deployed to the seafloor we also
surveyed the fauna using standard survey
techniques and we collect of organisms
for isotopic analysis so we can
reconstruct the food webs and how
they've changed since our previous trips
the water is negative 2 degrees Celsius
is very very cold and we have to dive
through 10 feet of sea ice in order to
access our study sites coming in under
the ice is quite surreal it's like
diving in Twilight because the light is
dim it's almost in some ways like diving
in outer space because of the vistas
that you get towards the underside of
the eyes will light going through and
the clarity of the water is this
unbelievable it's almost like you're
floating in air and floating in water I
[Music]
think
documenting what is down there now and
how it's changing over time
is really important this year all of us
were struck by just how quickly things
can change and it shows just how there
is essentially climate models that are
predicting changes in sea ice conditions
/ under the ice is pretty extreme it's
hard to keep the heat up at the hunt
because the the Sigma stoves are not
working that well that being said the
divers love diving under the ice because
of the beauty and the unique experience
that it provides meta rays are very
large they're one of the largest animals
in the ocean certainly they're the
largest of any of the Rays species they
can get up to about 25 feet across when
they come towards you and they're that
size they look like an alien spacecraft
as they go overhead they actually blight
out the Sun it's just so incredible to
be that close to such a large animal
especially one that you don't have to
fear
[Music]
my name is Andrea Marshall I'm a mentor
a researcher and a marine biologist I've
been in love with the ocean all of my
life ever since I could remember I
wanted to be a marine biologist when I
moved out to Africa with the intention
of studying things like great white
sharks I actually shifted my focus over
to manta rays when I realized that no
one had ever done a study on that race
before
[Music]
one of the things that makes Mantaray so
special is that they're large and
sometimes people feel frightened by them
just because of their sheer size but
actually they're one of the most gentle
animals in the entire ocean
[Music]
manta rays are a very intelligent animal
they actually have the largest brain of
any marine fish but one of the things
that surprises me the most is just the
fact that they seek out encounters with
humans so this isn't an animal that
swims away from you this is an animal
that swims to you they recognize you
almost as a friend
[Music]
southern Mozambique is just an
incredible location I've lived here for
the last 15 years and even though I
travel all over the world to do my work
I enjoy coming back here because this is
such a wild place it's so exciting one
of the reasons I began work on matches
is because I knew that these animals
were under threat recently you know
within the last 15 to 20 years they have
started to be fished for Asian tonics
and as a result of this we've seen Manta
populations crashing across the globe
even here in Mozambique where we don't
even have a very aggressive fishery
we've seen the population collapse by up
to about 98 percent over the last 15
years we're starting to lose them faster
than we can study them so it's really
important for me to get these messages
across to people who don't have the
opportunity to peek down into the
underwater world these are sea turtle
eggs and there are two ways this
situation can play out there's either or
there's
so how can we make sure this doesn't end
up like this well take a look again
these aren't your ordinary sea turtle
eggs these eggs could one day take down
an entire poaching network the story of
these eggs starts in Ann Arbor Michigan
hi I'm Kim William Skien and I am a
conservation ecologist Kim does research
on a wide variety of animals but we're
here to talk about endangered and
threatened sea turtles with sea turtles
in Central America there's an issue of
poaching of the nests for consumption of
the eggs and so her team has developed a
unique solution to gather more
information about the poaching trade
fake eggs with GPS trackers we can hide
these fake turtle eggs in sea turtle
nests our hope is that these eggs will
get poached along with the others and
transmit information on their locations
where is it that they go after they're
taken from the beach but for this to
work the fake eggs have to be convincing
they have to have the right feel because
sea turtle eggs are kind of a little
soft and squishy they're not like
chicken eggs we've been using a 3d
printer and a kind of flexible plastic
but they still don't look quite right
and this is when our story moves to Los
Angeles
hello I'm Lauren and Lauren works in
Hollywood my day-to-day job as I work on
set as a makeup artist which could be
beauty makeup prosthetics creature
design wigs blood so it made sense for
Lauren to help Kim make fake eggs we
needed these eggs to look realistic so
feel realistic and so that's kind of
where I've come in it was like the best
way that I could use my skills making
prosthetics but to actually like help a
whole species of turtles this is like
it's a dream job
after months of revisions it's time to
put these eggs to the test in Costa Rica
heigen you remember Kim she's here to
deploy the eggs herself on a protected
conservation area
this is a place that's very special
because it's a very important nesting
site tonight a sea turtle will come and
I can test out putting the false sea
turtle eggs in the nest not only will
this project provide Kim's team with
valuable information on poaching she and
Lauren hope it will inspire others as
well wildlife poaching can be abstract
or too depressing to even think about
something about this project kind of
captures people's attention here's this
very simple unique solution that I think
then serves as a jumping off point for
people's imaginations to learn more
about this trade all of us working on
this project are just doing it in our
our weird little nooks and wherever we
can and it just goes to show there's so
many little ways that everyone can help
you don't have to be making fake turtle
eggs to make a difference you can make a
difference in your own way
you